Ruby tries to trick me into thinking it
started when in fact it's just another
logo and because of this one minute and
five seconds of damn logos ichinose even
in the spirit realm who way is still
corporeal enough to feel itchy pick one
do all the rock formations and
structures that were destroyed in the
other two movies go to the same
afterlife as the kung-fu masters who
destroyed them it seems that way based
on new ways surroundings that's what
ended 500 years ago well now I'm ready
for a rematch by the looks of it kung-fu
masters maintain the physical form they
possess at the end of their life when
they go into the spirit realm which is
unfortunate new plays long and happy
life gives Kai the upper hand
Wei writes the Chinese symbol for Chi
backwards so that Kai and I guess the
audience can read it which is considered
oven with your Chi I will finally be
able to return to the mortal world but
why who set up this dumb world where if
you kill a whole bunch of masters in the
afterlife you get to go back and why is
Google a the last soul you need these
are some stupid rules after life I get
that this is just a cloud but all the
rhinos we've seen through the entire
series have been good guys the prison
guards Victor Garber the Rhino that was
in the suit that's in the Hall of
warriors if anything he should give this
cloud a friendly wave as he flies by po
just threw out his fist to begin falling
harder because he's also Kryptonian po
gets winded when he walks up the stairs
but running so fast his high-fives are
flammable there's no problem Shifu got
more goo slaves
I wonder how ping feels about this it's
just an intimidation thing because the
training home was pretty well lit before
these things were here hydrous was not
the Dragon Warrior you are why do I get
the feeling the Dragon Warrior is a
title given to suckers who have to end
up doing all the work what's that I hope
she foo hasn't been doing this the whole
time and all the operating has been
doing is just posed on perspective
tigress literally good shot with a
flaming arrow and responds like she
stubbed her toe Mike la vie mantis
doesn't know the technical term for his
appendage I'm clapping alright now what
a loser
look I know people forget about the
great deeds of heroes after a time but
in this world where kung-fu masters are
treated like gods who actually thinks PO
is a loser after two movies of
accidental awesomeness that they don't
know is accidental I think yes these
geese are English for some reason
speaking of English I'd like to
apologize for waiting until the third
movie to send this entire franchise for
being based on Chinese customs and
culture and only casting for Chinese
actor
in all three movies you set me up to
fail why because it keeps working
foolish how greatness in you Paul
against my better judgment
feels like Shifu should be over all this
by now after two movies and two major
victories that was G what's she G is a
fundamental principle of Chinese culture
that PO should already know after two
movies but he doesn't because the
audience might not know what it is
someone needs to explain it the energy
that flows through all living things
next thing you're gonna do is tell me
there's a dark side to all this and
people named Darth rhinoceros Kai's
return to the world of the living is a
ripoff of both Mortal Kombat and the
Terminator franchise Thai basically
draws a curved line in the dirt and for
some reason that keeps these guys from
continuing to run this goose laid some
eggs when you get scared because if it's
himself that would be a little too
graphic also isn't this goose a dude I
am ready
comical misdirection cliche aka the
basis behind every joke in this entire
franchise can someone get the Dragon
Warrior or a bigger tub to bathe in
silly noodles in the Jade Palace doesn't
seem like a good business idea there's
very little foot traffic up there no
because you didn't swallow them just
shoving food in your mouth doesn't count
I'm Li Shan I'm looking for my son the
first I had to beat your dumpling-eating
record which I guess is the first thing
everyone told me about when I came to
town I hope you find your sign and I
hope you find your father
we know PO is comically a nip so I'll
let this slide but why the hell is no
one else saying anything oh I mean he's
right but jumping to conclusions li and
po / Lotus are going to answer pings
question basically with we look alike
which proves nothing because all pandas
look the same that's racist sketch
bumming also the artist draws ping in
this picture even though he doesn't have
to receive a message if no one could
find you pink on the down I've got this
but yeah he's right does the Hall of
warriors rotate out artifacts every so
often or are all the artifacts in the
hall inexplicably different from the
first movie anything else we should try
bonding by way of vandalism mmm bond
dualism
this goes on for some time those
priceless artifacts are now going to get
scratched and they're going to ruin the
floor by sliding around on them so even
if they are caught right now someone
will know that someone up
who was pretty quickly everyone
immediately forgets about po playing
with the artifacts in the museum
immediately upon his father's revealed
zombies ah they beat me to it
Valley of Peace gets attacked every day
maybe they should change the name master
flies pose encyclopedic knowledge of all
the kung-fu masters who have ever
existed and his incessant need to
explain it is extremely convenient to us
the viewer otherwise they'd have to use
actual story to explain who these people
are
fighter who uses bow and arrow and never
runs out of arrows or in this instance
coils cliche years ago it is the fact
that he's entirely Jade not a huge red
flag to you
also remember jobbies include sketching
us the sketch pig was close enough for
po to retrieve him in seconds I see you
what is this guy Sauron he taught me how
to give Chi and you didn't teach anyone
else about it or tell PO you knew where
his cooking family was what could be
given could also be taken and turned
into a handy dandy little charm bracelet
so he won't lose it
i banished Chi to the spirit realm which
is a fancy way of saying you killed him
but this is a kids movie so also this
movie had to have been written as Mortal
Kombat extinction or Mortal Kombat
Apocalypse or whatever they're calling
the resident mortal evil x-men combat
underworld Furious movies these days
this is like the fourth montage in 30
minutes I raised PO for 20 years since
the lifespan of a panda is 20 years how
are all these older pandas not long debt
and PO not knocking on the spirit realms
door fly po didn't know ping could fly
and in the movie waste time making po
not know that we're here the Panda
villages beyond the wall they must be
wildlings how does this village manage
to be summary in the obviously ice-cold
mountains and god help you if you say
kaanchi
I've heard that word enough in this
movie to last a lifetime the Sun comes
out immediately upon their arrival in
the Panda city creating this dramatic
reveal
this pandas are out of shape Juke is
officially worn out its welcome
she's so handsome just like his father
thank you diddly tell the village
beforehand that he was bringing a
stranger into the secret village that no
outsiders are supposed to know about we
call it a snack list I was able to
resist eating it before they gave it to
him you're like me but all L know is
this thing's just what this franchisee
needed testicle jokes you merely eat one
at a time remember that fake movie
trailer called the fatties in Tropic
Thunder where Jack Black basically
played a whole family of fatties they
kind of made that movie here didn't they
potential I find it hard to believe PO
didn't realize this considering how many
times we've seen him shove spherical
food into his mouth in large quantities
she must really be the best ribbon
dancer in the world if she's able to
lasso PO like this and fling him around
the table when I'm breaking the ribbon
mayonnaise ribbon is getting longer
otherwise it would have been awfully
hard for PO to reach the table master
chicken is the only kung-fu master that
makes his animal noise on a regular
basis they must be in there
must they can you really just claim this
from the first structure you come upon
also there's a large boat in the middle
of the desert a desert that looks more
like Tatooine with rocks than a dry lake
so there's no reason for this boat to be
here even master chickens going in there
and he's a chicken he's also already a
kung-fu master which requires at least
some abandonment of the chicken
stereotype with the power that kind
possesses what the fuck is he doing
hiding up far away from the action
is there any reason why he hasn't just
one already he's got to wait until polar
and some way to defeat him then he'll
attack I guess it's just stupid I'll go
high you go low
mantis suggests that crane who was a
bird go low and he a bug goes high
weights up rain turns around a fight
when his time could have been better
spent getting the fuck away to warn his
friends head the sleep till past noon in
my opinion to sleep till past noon and
then does all the farming get done in
the heat of the afternoon poke killed
gramma panda that's how we get it
because tremendous appetite if you
didn't understand that pandas are fat
and enjoy food here's this pose dad is
remembering something he didn't witness
and the memory he couldn't possibly
remember is switching between 2d and 3d
animation because DreamWorks still can't
figure out how they want to do
flashbacks in these movies movie tries
to convince me they're just shooting
arrows between provinces to deliver
and not using slave geese or something
much more feasible to deliver messages
that's too lizard master ox Master Eagle
if you want to be a kung-fu master in
animal China you better hope there is an
already a member of your species that's
a kung fu master I know you're excited
to have more lines and screen time in
this movie monkey but let the Mantis go
the scroll the tigress needs to take
with her happens to fall out of the
destroyed Jade Palace and ends up right
next to her I don't know it okay no one
does there wasn't a single panda in that
village that knows Chi
even though it seems like a pretty
important thing to pass down now they're
all they're all even if PO wanted to say
they're dead he wouldn't be able to
because no one seems to actually die in
this universe except for Poe's
biological mother there are still
compounded wrecks after all this time I
lied to him for 20 years he still thinks
he came from an egg no he doesn't as the
last movie plainly pointed out he'd
pretty much bigger doubt the whole thing
but then you told him the story of how
you adopted him so you're lying to Poe's
dad right now yeah I don't even know if
I'm a panda I can help you out with that
one unless you had an army of your own
all of us
yes po build your child army also did
the fog clear dramatically just for this
review will be is slowly styling itself
to try and ease me into another training
montage it gets darker as Chi approaches
because he can also control the weather
so it's official
the pandas re walks like all the evil
creatures in this universe they can be
easily defeated with silliness the
kung-fu masters are all easily defeated
by these normal talking pandas I bet
they're just not used to the altitude
top yes kai is controlling all the Jade
masters with his mind and his eye of
Sauron thing but how did he keep track
of all of them when they split up
does he have sour on picture-in-picture
or does he have to use the last button
on his Sauron remote and switch back and
forth wait it's working no it's not I
must be trying a silliness fighting
technique to defeat Bo but it's
definitely not working stick with what
you know Chi Chi takes the time to beat
on PO instead of just taking in Chi
because the movie needed some more run
time I can't send you there but I can
take you there
Duke's PO Russia fingers himself and it
actually works instead of PO going to
the spirit realm by himself leaving Chi
there to steal everyone's cheat and
we'll finish it here then we're with a
loser go the further the transformation
of PO into a jade thingy takes way
longer than normal
giving the pandas an opportunity to pull
Chi out of their ass you told us who we
were meant to be in like a day these
pandas find sudden Chi by believing in
themselves which means they simply
needed to locate Kanye West to defeat
the bad guy I am the Dragon Warrior
basically this movie is just telling us
we're all with it we're making this up
as we go along
just ignore whether or not we're making
sense roll with it we're making this a
Chitty Chitty chat shit yeah kinda has
basically the same weaknesses 2015 in
1885 Marty McFly when I sent the message
to your father just in case you're one
of the few people who didn't figure this
out on your own we I can go back who
knows I've never tried then PO tries the
first thing you think so and it works I
think I mastered G like in 10 seconds
though really didn't have to work at all
to get that knowledge what a cheat sheet
can you teach me well maybe you should
ask the congregation of pandas around
you because they are the ones who
learned how to do cheat they just
transferred the power from the mortal
realm into the spirit realm and infused
PO with it so no you can't teach you
accept this movie is going to have you
believe you can't so
what took away and other masters decades
to learn this group of animals learn in
a matter of days I'm Wilford Brimley and
I'd like to talk to you for a few
minutes about diabeetus
in that shampoo is better I go on first
and clean the hair I hope you find your
son hope you find your dad I left my
friends unprotected and now they're all
they're all and you would have been too
I watched Jane die
god damn time-traveling robots covered
up their goddamn tracks knew it
vacation homes